hey guys it's November second and
already I'm running low on Halloween
candy so please send reinforcements I'm
fastening covering for Jess here are
today's stories first up it may be too
soon to say goodbye to the Wii U
Nintendo is denying reports of ending
production this week earlier this week
it was reported that Nintendo would
cease production on the Wii U this
coming Friday November forth multiple
sources told Eurogamer that this would
be the case a Nintendo declined to
comment on their story now Japan's IT
media quotes a Nintendo spokesperson as
denying that production on the Wii U
will end this week there is no change to
our continuing production the
spokesperson said as translated by
Kotaku stating that they were not aware
of the specifics of the original report
that said the person explained that the
reports about the wii u production
coming to a close are not true even
though the nintendo switch is slated to
go on sale we you productions scheduled
to continue the spokesperson said adding
that more wii u games are on the way
including The Legend of Zelda breath of
the wild fun fact about that new Mass
Effect Andromeda trailer the main
characters father was the narrator
creative director Mac Walters confirmed
on Twitter that the new Mass Effect
Andromeda trailer released this week was
narrated by the main character writers
father in response to someone's question
riders father whose name has not been
disclosed spoke about the mysterious
Andromeda initiative the exact nature of
which has not been confirmed the time
has come to prepare ourselves for a
future beyond the Milky Way a future
that begins 600 years from where we
stand in a time and a place among
unknown stars and unseen dangers riders
father says some have been wondering
about the 600 years remark is and drama
set six hundred years after mass effect
3 someone asked us to producer Michael
gamble on Twitter but he didn't give
anything away we said 600 years but from
one he said that we did not say Walters
Andromeda's creative director was also
asked if one of the characters shown in
the video was writers mother that wasn't
her he confirmed in another tweet
Bioware will share more details on who
this woman is on november seventh which
is also known as n7 day to fans of the
spacefaring RPG series and finally we've
got details and watchdogs tues dlc and
season pass with watchdogs to coming out
in two weeks Ubisoft has finally shared
some details on what you can expect to
find in the DLC packs which
to the ps4 first the first of the DLC
packs arrives in December introducing a
new truck and outfit as well as a new
co-op difficulty level called mayhem it
remains to be seen how extensive the
changes in mayhem will be but Ubisoft
says it introduces a new enemy type that
uses advanced weaponry to other bigger
packs follow the first DLC sometime next
spring those will add new missions and a
co-op mode called showdown the details
of which are pretty vague the season
pass also comes with access to to
customization DLC packs there's also
some minor DLC available to amazon prime
members you can check out Ubisoft's
official descriptions for everything on
gamespot com the season pass for
watchdogs to is priced at forty dollars
and is included with the gold edition
still no word on what pricing will be
for the DLC packs individually all
post-launch DLC for watchdogs to comes
to ps4 30 days before other platforms
watchdogs to a set for launch on
November 15th for Xbox one and ps4 PC
players will have to wait a little bit
longer following a recent delay on
November 29 let me know what you think
about today's stories in the comments
below and don't forget that next week we
have extra life going on from Friday to
Sunday November 11 to 13 at 72 hours
long Ruby raising money for charity it's
all for the kids so please check it out
we're gonna be streaming games the whole
time so donate and check it out and I'll
see you tomorrow